en pologne nouveau face à face entre
solidarité le pouvoir les ouvriers de
danse menacent de se mettre en grève si
j'arrive health qui ne reconnaît pas à
leur syndicat pauline lafont se
cache-t-elle où était séquestrée
des témoins l'auraient vu dans une
voiture cela fait maintenant huit jours
que la comédienne a disparu
l'armée israélienne on l'appelle ça râle
c'est l'armé la plus secrète du monde
reportage exclusif dans ce journal
d'anne loustallot à déjouer la censure
israélienne cyclisme sean kelly et
jean-françois bernard aux côtés de
laurent fignon cyrille guimard sur le
point de reconstituer une grande équipe
bonsoir
avant de développer tous ces titres le
soudan comme l'egypte de la bible le
soudan doit faire face à toute une série
de malédiction après la guerre civile et
la sécheresse s'étend ce seul mois
d'août deux véritables catastrophes qui
se sont abattues sur ce pays les plus
torrentielles et ensuite les cris qui
lie à oslo dans un million et demi de
sinistrés menaces et maintenant par les
maladies jacques des faits rendus au
soudan
reportage
il ne reste pratiquement rien de ce
quartier dans de khartoum parvenir est
presque devenu un exploit les pistes ont
disparu englouti les maisons construites
en terre se sont écroulés elles ont
littéralement fondu sous les pluies
diluviennes en emmenant les quelques
effets qu'ils ont pu sauver les
habitants ont fui vers quelques îlots
rester au sec ou vers des campements de
fortune on avait une maison allait
tomber avec les premières pluies
maintenant on a fait cette petite case
on n'a qu'un kilo de farine par jour au
marché on trouve absolument rien je suis
enceinte et je n'arrive à faire qu'un
repas par jour avec mes enfants quand on
en fait deux c'est vraiment une
exception que les départements du marché
noir
d'ailleurs s'il y en a un qui s'est fait
prendre avec seize sacs de farine qui
ont finalement été distribués aux
passants et puis l'aide elle va plutôt
aux sympathisants du pouvoir surtout
ceux du front islamique dans ce pays
déjà cruellement d organiser sur le plan
politique et administratif les
inondations ne font qu'aggraver les
insuffisances avec par ci par là
les ânes délicatesse qu'on imagine pour
l'instant les rappelait alimentaires
n'arrivent pas jusqu'aux sinistrés
les réserves de farine ont été ont été
mouillés donc les gens tournent encore
sur une réserve de farine mouillé mais
encore utilisables qui va finir par
courir très rapidement par moisir très
rapidement et il a le poil notionnels va
se faire assure jours donc on espère que
les distributions comment seront
relativement rapidement situation
sanitaire également alarmante typhoïde
hépatites paludisme peut être même
choléra les épidémies menacent des
millions de sinistrés
le besoin est urgent de médicaments et
de tablettes pour purifier l'eau
médecins sans frontières a déjà installé
quatre dispensaires je viens du cordeau
femmes et enfants sont tous malades ils
vomissent tout le temps il ya de la
dysenterie de la malaria partout et
l'aide qu'on a reçues c'était du pain
sec c'est tout le gouvernement de
khartoum et l'armée soudanaise tente de
faire face en érigeant par exemple ici
un camp de toile mais leur action est
contesté et plusieurs aussi ses
supérieurs ont déjà été limogés
c'est le seul terrain sec de khartoum
il appartient à l'état et les avantages
c'est qu'il est un peu en hauteur
d'ailleurs vous pouvez le voir les
dernières pluies n'ont pratiquement rien
faire ici
la situation météo est grave le nil bleu
continuent de gonfler et menacent
l'ensemble de la capitale soudanaise
cette tragédie pourrait donc encore
s'aggraver en aval au contraire en
egypte les crues limoneuses sont
toujours une bénédiction
malheureusement le soudan n'est pas un
don du nil en pologne une fois encore de
force l'une contre l'autre d'un côté le
pouvoir du général jaruzelski
de l'autre côté le syndicat solidarité
est aujourd'hui un nouveau seuil a été
franchi dans l' escalade de la
contestation
les ouvriers de gdansk menacent de
rejoindre la grève si le pouvoir ne
légalise pas le syndicat solidarité
jacques merino lie à 8 ans naissait ici
dans les chantiers navals danse
le syndicat clandestins solidarité
c'était le 31 août 1980 ce matin dans
les mêmes chantier les ouvriers se sont
réunis et ont lancé une véritable
déclaration de guerre au pouvoir
reconnaissez notre syndicat donnez lui
une vie les galons il enseignera aux
skis sinon dès lundi prochain
nous nous mettrons nous aussi en grève
cette décision d'un seul coup a
complètement modifié le sens de
différents mouvements qui se développe
en pologne les mineurs à katowice cube
plusieurs puits depuis lundi dernier et
ont accroché sur les grilles de l'entrée
principale cette banderole pas de
liberté sans solidarité grève aussi dans
les ports notamment à chet chine où les
3000 le caire ont cessé le travail il
est en métal combien de temps peut-on
souffrir comme cela c'est de pire en
pire
joseph qui nous annonce trois mois de
calme c'est qu'est ce qu'il a fait
pendant huit ans c'est pire qu'avant
quelques arrestations de courte durée
ont été effectuées par la police mais un
roi clos on est sans nouvelles depuis
hier soir de radis cela fera six nuke
l'un des leaders les plus dures de
solidarité d'importantes forces de
sécurité encerclent toutes les usines
occupées mais il semble bien ce soir que
la détermination des grévistes soient de
plus en plus forte
l'énigme pauline pauline lafont pardon
en france chaque année dix mille
personnes disparaissent quand il s'agit
d'une comédienne connue la faire bien
sûr prend une résonance particulière
la thèse d'un accident a maintenant été
pratiquement abandonné par les
enquêteurs les témoignages qu'ils ont
recueillis laissent penser que pauline
lafont est bien parti en auto-stop
mais que s'est il passé après dominique
verdeilhan j'ai vu pauline le témoignage
d'une automobiliste de montélimar
relance l'enquêté sur la disparition de
l'actrice
les enquêteurs s'intéressent désormais à
une golf blanche immatriculée en suisse
c'est à son bord mercredi soir que
l'actrice aurait été aperçu en compagnie
de deux hommes
selon ce témoin qui n'a pas relevé le
numéro d'immatriculation de la voiture
elle semblait ni traquer ni menacées ce
nouveau témoignage conforte les
enquêteurs qui penche de plus en plus
pour la thèse de la fugue
les gendarmes sont désormais convaincus
que la jeune femme blonde aperçu il ya
plus d'une semaine sur le bord de cette
départementale par ce fermier de
saint-andré-de-valborgne était bien
pauline lafont
selon lui l'auto stoppeuse portait une
robe rouge à rayures blanches
on y était bon j'étais virale vous
comprenez là que ça s'est bien passé
et avec 2 novembre aux moeurs roujan des
rainures blanche je suis mauvais
un détail important car david lafond a
confirmé que sa soeur possède des biens
ce vêtement et que celui ci reste
aujourd'hui introuvable dans ses
affaires
david qui ne croit pas à la fugue et qui
à cet après-midi déposé une plainte
contre x pour arrestation et
séquestration illégale très proche en
outre on s'aime beaucoup ne revenez
jamais laisser comme ça sans nouvelles
pendant huit jours c'est pas possible
si la plainte déposée par david lafond
est enregistrée par le parquet de nîmes
elle permettrait l'ouverture d'une
enquête placé sous l'autorité d'un juge
d'instruction
la nouvelle calédonie les discussions
devaient aboutir devrait aboutir très
rapidement c'est louis le pensec le
ministre des dom tom qui l'a dit tout à
l'heure en arrivant à l'hôtel matignon
et à l'instant j'apprends que pierre
bérégovoy le ministre des finances vient
d'annoncer que le gouvernement a prévu
de débloquer une somme de 300 millions
de francs pour la nouvelle calédonie en
cas d'accord le premier ministre michel
rocard recevait en effet ce soir les
deux délégations du rpcr et du fln caf
rachid arhab fait le point sur une
nouvelle journée de négociation une
pause dans le marathon le fn ksc le rpcr
ont quitté le ministère des dom tom où
il négocie pratiquement sans
interruption depuis deux jours pour une
petite pause à matignon une récréation
au cours de laquelle les deux
délégations sont reçus par michel rocard
visite de politesse nous dit on mais dès
ce soir les discussions reprendront chez
louis le pensec des discussions qui sont
apparemment bien avancé le ministre des
dom-tom et tout à fait optimiste
nous progressons donc résolument nous
avançons mathématiquement puisque de 37
articles nous sommes passés à 100 nous
avançons aussi j'veux pas pouvoir vivre
politiquement nous avons aussi avancé
financièrement puisque nous nous sommes
mis d'accord sur l'ensemble des
dispositions financières qui régissent
les relations entre l'état la province
les provinces et le territoire
l'approbation par les délégations du
projet de loi sur le statut de la
nouvelle calédonie est donc en très
bonne voie
il reste encore quelques points délicats
à régler toujours la fameuse question de
l'amnistié dont on reparlera la nuit
prochaine
mais l'accord final semble être possible
pour demain air inter les syndicats face
à face ce soir la cfdt la cgc et la cftc
dénonce l' égoïsme des autres syndicats
de pilotes et navigants qui refusent
vous le savez le pilotage à 2 des airbus
a320
il juge que ce conflit est uniquement
corporatiste examen de passage presque
réussi à la nouvelle orléans pour george
bush lui qui avait une réputation un peu
molle a tenu un discours très ferme à la
clôture de la convention républicaine
d'ailleurs pour la première fois les
sondages le donnent en tête 45 % contre
44 % d'intentions de vote face à duke a
kiss en revanche son nouveau co listiers
dan quayle à lui pose déjà des problèmes
on l'accuse de cette planque et pour ne
pas aller faire la guerre au vietnam
jacquat bouchard on ferme à la nouvelle
orléans
moins d'une heure après les ultimes
festivités les lâchers de ballons et les
chants des délégués les déménageurs
prenait possession du superdome cette
dernière soirée aurait dû s'achever en
apothéose pour le candidat georges
gouttes
certes il a eu sa part d'acclamations
d'ovations sans doute son discours at il
plu mais la cérémonie du sac a été
gâchée dans la coulisse ont commenté -
l'intervention du vice-président que les
problèmes de son colistier d'un coup
elle appelé sous les drapeaux en 1969
est donc entré dans la garde nationale
de son état natal line diana
contrairement à 300 mille jeunes
américains envoyés au vietnam en 69
il est donc resté douillettement à la
maison sa famille influente dans
l'indiana est propriétaire d'un grand
journal alors que dans quoi elle très
populaire chez lui siège pour sénat de
washington depuis 1981 l'image du fils à
papa pistonné vient donc immédiatement à
l'esprit ce qui n'est pas très glorieux
pour un candidat à la vice-présidence
la presse est aux aguets l'équipe de
george bush sur le qui vive
malgré un optimisme de façade dans quoi
elle va devoir jouer serré dans les
prochains jours le pentagone reconnaît
les torts de la marine américaine
l'équipage du vincennes a bien fait des
erreurs la frégate vincennes avait
abattu le 3 juillet dernier un airbus y
règne un dans le golfe persique
mais le pentagone a tenu tout de même la
responsabilité du capitaine et son
équipage en raison de la tension très
vive qui qui avait lieu à ce moment-là à
la proche de l'avion salle c'est l'armée
israélienne s'est alarmée du secret en
ce moment cette armée qui tentent de
faire régner l'ordre avec beaucoup de
difficultés dans les territoires occupés
par israël aujourd'hui encore quatre
palestiniens ont été blessés par balles
dont un très grièvement dans la bande de
gaza et il y a eu de nouveaux
affrontements en cisjordanie l'armée
israélienne s'est en effet l'une des
armées les plus secrètes du monde secret
des lieux secrets des hommes et surtout
secret des images
la censure est impitoyable dan
loustallot a voulu mieux comprendre
comment et pourquoi cette armée
fonctionne dans un tel mystère
voici son reportage elle a réussi à
ramener des images que l'armée
israélienne elle-même avait censuré un
mig 15 égyptiens qui est abattu dans le
sinaï devenant durant la campagne de
cinar 1956 de fabrication soviétique
c'est un virage 3 qu'elle savait de on
dit de très bons services
la défense du pays devant nous nous
avons un éclair la gloire de talent le
passé victorieux et au grand jour le
présent est sous haute surveillance un
reportage dans une base aérienne entre
un agent de la sécurité et un officier
de liaison des images contrôlées par la
censure militaire
vous avez aussi des gaz et de conseils
des officiers de l'aviation et combien
de cas 7 3 on peut le prendre mon profil
le premier pilote est pas qu on le voit
en face il faut ôter la séquence où on
voit leurs hangars de la de l'avion
l'aviation c'est l'assurance-vie
d'israël le pays a le dos à la mer des
frontières étroites et des voisins
hostiles
la première ligne de défense est une
riposte est clair grâce à des avions
sophistiqués ils sont américains et des
pilotes des pilotes sur entraînés
capables de frapper vite et fort dans le
ciel d'israël et au delà
on se souvient des attaques de
l'aviation israélienne en irak ou en
plus vous avez fait des opérations
spéciales à l'étranger oui mais je ne
peux pas trop en parler
l'officier de liaison est intervenu le
sujet est top secret osirak le
bombardement de la centrale nucléaire en
irak
ce n'est plus un secret vous pouvez m'en
parler j'ai lu les mêmes journaux vous
j'en ai entendu parler
alors qu avez vous lu que c'était un
réacteur nucléaire en irak qu'il était
dangereux pour israël est ce que c'est
la raison pour laquelle à l'époque
l'opération avait été décidée en
amérique où vous avez le nombre de bases
et le fait que le délai soit de
téléphone c'est une chaîne où ces
questions de la possibilité que ce
qu'une personne soit plus honni et de
guerre prisonnier de guerre
le mot est lâché israël vit comme un
pays en guerre
un soldat capturé surtout si les pilotes
sera l'objet d'un chantage la parade
l'homme doit être impossible à
identifier
la consigne pas de visage pas de nom pas
d'insigne la défense d'israël repose sur
la haute technicité de ses hommes et de
son matériel
mais le potentiel humain est limité car
l'équation est simple 4 millions
d'israéliens face à 150 millions
d'arabes toute bataille gagnée par
israël devient une défaite si les hommes
n'en reviennent pas le véritable secret
d'israël ce n'est pas cet avion ce sont
ces soldats
ici tout est à visage découvert les
soldats les chars le terrain nous sommes
dans une unité de blindés quelque part
dans le nord d'israël
si vous avez donc votre commentaire la
location est exact des lieux ne fait pas
rentrer dans le commentaire
si on ne voit rien il ya pas de mental
il n'y a rien qui puisse montrer la
location
en somme rien qui puisse révéler où se
trouvent ces soldats et ce qu'ils font
en fait le secret n'est pas gardée par
la censure mais par les soldats de même
c'est l'autocensure à l'israélienne des
leur incorporation on a inculqué à ses
hommes une consigne qu'ils garderont
toute leur vie observé le silence absolu
sur talent car salle est un paradoxe
c'est l'une des armées les plus
performants du monde et pourtant ce
n'est pas une armée de métier c'est une
armée de civils conscrits et réservistes
ni à leur famille ni à leurs amis ses
soldats ne diront où ils vont et ce
qu'ils font
vous qui avez été aussi dit bon on a
dernièrement ou pas toute action qui se
passe en dehors des serait de rester
dans l'armée
une indiscrétion nous laissent penser
que des soldats de cette unité ont
participé à une récente opération au sud
liban le liban est une épine dans le
flanc de talent parce que l'occupation
israélienne au liban de 82 à 85 a terni
l'image de l'armée et qu'elle n'a pas
résolu le problème du terrorisme
le sud liban reste une base pour les
commandos terroristes qui tentent de
s'infiltrer en israël
par des opérations coup de poing à
val-des-monts fait régulièrement leurs
positions très peu d'information
officielle sur ces raids et absence de
commentaires de la part des soldats
vous pouvez me parler des derniers
combats de l'armée israélienne au sud je
n'ai pas envie d'en parler c'est une
histoire trop récente c'est tout vous
avez combien d'hommes dans votre unité
et quand je ne peux pas vous le dire
pourquoi ses secrets oui c'est pas un
grand secret mais ses secrets vous
pouvez me parler de la lutte contre le
terrorisme
je ne peux pas vous parler précisément
technique technique mais et je peux vous
dire que toutes les nuits nous
patrouillons long de la frontière
d'israël et que et que si quelqu'un
s'approche de nos lignes par exemple
nous montions et shoot après quatre
guerres livrées au grand jour contre des
armées arabes salvi maintenant une
guerre de l'ombre
la nuit tombe le travail des soldats de
tsahal continue les autres faits
marquants de l'actualité en bref avec
françoise joly des images qui ce soir
nous viennent tout d'asie de l'irak à la
birmanie en passant par l'afghanistan et
le pakistan
élections aujourd'hui en birmanie du
nouveau président de la république et du
parti unique monsieur mangue mangue
il est le premier dirigeant birman
civile depuis 26 ans il succède au
général singing qui a démissionné le 12
août dernier
messieurs mangue est pour l'instant
resté silencieux devant la principale
revendication des manifestants
l'organisation d'un référendum sur un
retour à la démocratie
pas moins de 24 heures du cessez le feu
entre l'iran et l'irak les derniers
contingent des casques bleus de l'onu
sont arrivés aujourd'hui à téhéran
dès ce soir 350 d'entre eux prendront
position des deux côtés de la frontière
dans les prochaines semaines ils seront
mille cinq cents à veiller au respect du
cessez le feu dès demain irak devrait
reprendre son trafic maritime commercial
dans le golfe
le fils du président pakistanais zia
ul-haq accuse urss d'avoir trempé dans
l'attentât qui a coûté la vie à son père
deux équipes d'experts américains se
sont rendus aujourd'hui au pakistan pour
tenter de déterminer les causes de la
catastrophe
les obsèques du président dia auront
lieu demain à la grande mosquée
d'islamabad en présence de nombreuses
délégations étrangères
600 à 800 soviétique et afghan sont
morts dans l'attaqué de la base de kémag
et au nord de kaboul une attaque menée
par la résistance afghane
la base de telagh et abriter des stocks
de carburant et de munitions pour deux
ans ce qui explique le bilan très lourd
de cette offensive des moudjahidine
c'est l'opération militaire la plus
meurtrière depuis le début de
l'intervention soviétique en afghanistan
en 1979 cyclisme jean françois bernard
et sean kelly dans l'équipe système u
c'est presque fait cyrille guimard se
plaignait la semaine dernière de voir
ses vedettes partir en fait il a agi
très vite pour récupérer de vrais
leaders tout pourrait se conclure dans
les prochains jours enquête francis
maroteaux claude et marc cyrille guimard
a retrouvé le sourire et pourtant
rappelez vous la semaine passée il nous
apprenait que trois de ses éléments
quitter système u 3 et non des moindres
charly mottet
eric boyer et joël peut lier aujourd'hui
le moral est au beau fixe
sean kelly et jean-françois bernard
pourrait rejoindre sa formation
j'ai eu l'occasion de rencontrer sean
kelly qui est d'une part à beaucoup de
propositions qui sont dans une situation
très délicate puisque le groupe cast
annoncé son départ dans l'immédiat il
souhaiterait lui pouvoir continuer avec
la même structure la même équipe et
éventuellement avec un autre sponsor
donc les choses se décanteront pas tout
de suite
quant à bernard si les contacts sont
moins avancés sa venue dans l'équipe
système u serait vue d'un bon oeil par
guimard et par fignon
jean françois bernard également
m'intéresse dans la mesure où c'est un
garçon qui a encore un potentiel énorme
et après avoir discuté longuement avec
laurent fignon s'est passé c'est un
couple qui vit père a dit kelly seraient
réservées pour les grandes classiques
bernard et fignon plutôt pour les
courses à étapes
mais problème si les deux venus se
confirmer guimard serait obligé de
trouver un deuxième sponsor une
formation ça coûte de plus en plus cher
donc les règles du jeu ont été
énormément changé depuis quelques années
avec l'arrivée de gros sponsors en trop
de gens comme bernard tapie qui ont
cherché tout de suite avoir une équipe
une équipe compétitive
évitant de faire de la formation donc il
fallait bien que qu'ils aillent chercher
des coureurs de valeur dans les autres
équipes c'est également vrai pour
d'autres équipes que ce soit hollande en
belgique ou en espagne
cyrille guimard n'attend désormais plus
que la signature des deux grands
champions mais on ne peut d'ores et déjà
dire qu'il a retrouvé un certain appétit
séoul c'est dans moins d'un mois
maintenant dans quatre semaines en effet
les jeux olympiques de séoul seront
inaugurés la liste des sportifs français
sélectionnée et rendue publique
aujourd'hui ils sont 286 peu de
surprises mais quelques déceptions
pierre quinon champion olympique de saut
à la perche à los angeles n'est pas
sélectionné en cyclisme même chose
richard vivien champion du monde en 87
n'est pas sur la liste
en athlétisme il y encore un meeting
prestigieux sept à bruxelles cette fois
pour le mémorial van damme déjà
plusieurs épreuves viennent d'avoir lieu
le 100 m avec bien sûr en vedette carl
lewis le voit si vous allez le voir
c'est le grand favori puisque la semaine
dernière il avait battu ben johnson à
zurich en 9 secondes
93 dans cette course il n'a pas vraiment
d'adversaire même si dennis mitchell
à sa gauche prend le meilleur départ
mais bien sûr superbe accélération de
lewis au 60 m comme d'habitude elle
champion américain l'emportant 10
secondes 05 100e c'est tout de même un
excellent temps voici de nouveaux sont
arrivés au ralenti voilà pour le sport
ils sont jeunes souvent beau toujours
bronzé ce ne sont pas les sportifs mais
ce sont ceux que vous voyez tous les
jours sur la plage même si son sportif
pendant l'été ce sont eux qui vous
portent les matelas par exemple ou qui
vous servent à boire en fait souvent
leur situation n'est pas si simple car
il travaille seulement durant la saison
et ce n'est pas toujours facile de s'en
sortir dans ces conditions sur la plage
de cavalaire au soleil bien sûr alain
doublé ce qui est daniel levy ont
rencontré un plagiste un de ces
saisonniers
reportage j'ai 28 ans
et fait ce travail depuis combien de
temps disons je le fais à peu près une
heure
une dizaine d'années dispersés au hasard
des saisons des régions leur travail
le bien-être des eaux sans histoire prêt
à louer leurs services
été comme hiver ils sont 200 à 300
milles en france dans ce cas un tiers
sont permanentes très qualifiés maître
d'hôtel ou cuisiniers par exemple les
autres ont des contrats pour une saison
dans le meilleur des cas
yves hadash ans employé de plage d'été
l'hiver il a une spécialité l'hiver je
suis moniteur de ski dans les alpes du
sud à valberg ont peu de ces années
toute sa vie je ne sais pas disons que
pour l'instant c'est un boulot qui me
convient bien et vous êtes mariés non
mais j'ai une petite amie qui travaille
d'ailleurs ici à la plage qui s'occupe
des locations de pédalos vivre en couple
c'est encore le meilleur moyen trouvé
par les saisonniers pour mieux supporter
le déracinement mais un problème se pose
celui du logement dans les zones
touristiques
les locations ne correspondent pas aux
moyens des saisonniers l'hébergement à
plusieurs par chambre est souvent la
seule solution
la réglementation sanitaire pas toujours
respectée conditions de vie
précarisation de l'emploi aboutissent
parfois à la marginalisation de plus
travaillant dans des régions de forte
activité trop occupé la formation
professionnelle leur est pratiquement
interdite
disons que oui qu'on n'est pas mal
occupé mais disons que la formation se
fait sur le tas et on apprend de soi
même travail saisonnier d'un but au bout
à part entière et que qu'il faut quand
même donné beaucoup de mal pour arriver
trouver ce qu'il faut l'été l'hiver si
vous tombez malade qu'est ce qui se
passe vous êtes payés ben disons pas
vraiment mais nous avons des assurances
personnelles et votre retraite vous y
pensez bon c'est sûr je cotise une
retraite personnelle ligne est bien avec
lui ça va c'est raisonnable
yves et sa compagne s'en sortent bien
par rapport à beaucoup d'autres ils ont
un capital leur jeep plus de jet ski
qu'il loue pour leur propre compte à un
début d'indépendance en somme
en effet le seul avenir pour les
saisonniers c'est devenir patron un jour
après avoir franchi tous les obstacles
enfin cette information ouf les anglais
sont rassurés car le suspense devenait
torride depuis 11 jours les commères de
windsor se rongeaient d'inquiétude mais
la nouvelle a soulagé tout le royaume
uni la petite princesse d'york qui est
né le 8 août dernier qui est la fille du
prince andrew et de la princesse sarah
qui est donc la petite fille de la reine
où elle a enfin un prénom elle s'appelle
béatrice voilà demain il y à un tiercé
quarté + c'est à deauville alors voici
les pronostics de pierrette brès 10 4 11
13 3 7 6 et 9 tout de suite vous allez
rendez vous avec josé blanc lapierre pas
très optimiste pour sa météo qui sera
complète vous le verrez ensuite la
dernière édition du journal et bien ce
sera vers 23h20 philippe lefait puis
demain pour les journaux vous avez
rendez vous à être des petits bureaux et
daniel bilalian excellente soirée sur
antenne 2